open our working session our work
session of division three
um we really have
two actions today
for the work session and I don't think
these are controversial because we we
discuss them
uh the the on the um first one
dealing with
1193 the that's the amendment number
it's dealing with the transfers uh uh
from The Liquor Commission fund
and uh this language for those of you
that read all of these things very
carefully is
modify just a little bit because it met
the Departments you know wanted to
suggest slightly different language Mr
Ripple assures me that it doesn't change
our policy or the concept it's just
happier words
so that that's though that's 1193
and then the other document that's
the issue we had with that full body
scanner that we want to have the sununu
center do is we we're going to put it in
the footnote that they could move money
around but apparently that's
unconstitutional to basically uh put up
make a the effect of a law in a footnote
of hb1
so so it's the it's the same thing but
it just has to be go live in hb2
so
um
so I think that I'm going to ask for a
straw vote
on the hb2 item to approve the uh the
transfer Authority and the purchasing of
the full body scanner all or is there
could I actually ask a question about
the look at one
we'll get to that honestly right now I'm
on the scanner
yeah any questions or comments about
this no that's all right
um I you actually didn't miss anything I
don't think this is very controversial
so so what what what what is happening
is we all agreed we want the body
scanner and we in in exchange for having
the body scanner at sununu we're going
to liberate their ability to to move
money around between uh expense line
lines
they can't we can't do that in hb1 it's
it's has the effect of a law and so we
have to put it in hb2 so so the one
document you have on hb2 is exactly what
we agreed to but as an hb2 item do you
want do you want to say something about
this Mr Ripple
that's actually that's exactly right uh
the courts have ruled that house bill
one can't contain any uh modifications
to or suspensions of state law so I
would request that you put this in the
trailer Bill instead
all right so
um I'd like a show of hands those in
favor of accepting the the full body
scanner at sununu in hb2 raise your hand
please
okay just clarify I I agree
um it's this is just an unofficial draft
yes I didn't I thought of this too late
uh to have OLS draft it but now that
you've adopted it I'll have OLS draft a
so the next one uh representative erf is
the Liquor Commission fund transfer item
1193 do you have questions or comments
I'm just curious I was reading their
audit this morning uh probably need Mr
Ripple for this
I was learning the audit this morning
the Liquor Commission is this in any way
related to the fact that they didn't pay
the full amount or didn't transfer the
full amount into the uh
alcohol abuse thing I I don't think it's
foreign
so I think this is just executing what
we'd already agreed on so I I would like
to go ahead and see a show of hands on
who can accept this as
part of hb2
okay that's it and then you have a third
item for us that's for information I
understand yes you don't need to vote on
this you voted on it on Tuesday but I
have the revised rate increase Amendment
and although there's no vote go ahead
and take your time and just look at it
over and if you if you want to come back
Mr Lipman sir did you get a copy of The
Proposal okay
Mr Ripple when we finish here
do I need to recess do we have anything
else outstanding that may come back over
I see no reason to recess
okay
all right
uh representative Mooney
thank you Mr chair so as we review
Amendment 1183 H as I recall from last
we met the critical sections are on page
three
the insertion of Roman 19
as well as
section three
so on page three that would be line 12
do we have the total of what this
document he can tell us again I I think
it was uh 70.4 plus 24. 70.2 plus 24
million over the over the biennium
so 70
70.2 0.2 and 24. the 24 was the 3.1
percent base and then we allocated the
70.2 to help rate increases
uh so I just um uh want to make sure
that the department is
um and the language is clear to indicate
how they can use the 12 and 12. um uh uh
money's uh timing wise and to uh are
they target is there any formula for
targeting the rate rate increase in here
uh to individual areas or do they just
have uh total total discretion to use it
on on rates in any way that they see
based on this language thanks
I think our intent was to let them have
whatever flexibility they needed in
order to make sure that everyone got 3.1
percent that we didn't Overlook any
entity and that if anything popped up
the department could handle it obviously
excluding the hospital portion
that is correct I just would like to ask
one question though there was some
discussion back and forth that the
committee about
um DME and and the pharmacy issue I
think where you landed was this
where the governor talked about us for
services and I'm not sure this whether
the um this Clarity on those two pieces
for us uh
um but I think we can work with what's
here I think the clarity was we decided
to accept the governor's proposal around
DME and pharmacies that what what he was
recommending was what we're supporting I
it was there any other position on the
other than that
I don't think so okay thank you yes sir
all right so I'm sorry you all came in
because we're already done I could I
could read it back into the record how
great it is that I think we cooperated
to to come up with a Medicaid rate
increase that met the community's
requests that used available funds to
the extent that we had them and that
we're going to give the Senate something
really useful to work with so so I like
all that so go ahead represent walner
well
I don't think we really actually met the
request of the providers I think we're
this document is considerably lower than
what the information they provided us
okay uh I don't need to recess this the
work session is done
congratulations division three you we've
we're done right we've done all of our
work and now we have to the only thing
we have left is to go back into full
committee and vote this out that's
correct as far as the budget goes you do
have bills at 10 o'clock right the four
bills ten o'clock all right we are
adjourned
foreign
now 1003 on Friday March 24th we're
going to open up this work session on
four bills that need addressing
so just to refresh everybody's memory
the bills to be recommended or not what
have you today during this work session
are as follows so it's house bills 91.
and 6 14.
now this day has been long incoming as
we were supposed to have worked on these
during the snowstorm and they were put
off until today so I think we're going
on two and a half weeks to familiarize
ourselves with these bills and take a
recommended action
so for those in the audience and at home
I'm representative Maureen Mooney the
vice chair of division three our
chairman representative Jess Edwards has
another commitment this morning
so with that uh why don't we go right in
order if there is nothing to start out
with does any member have anything to
say to begin
real good we'll start with house bill
91.
so House Bill 91 relative to privacy
obligations to the Department of Health
and Human Services we may recall that
this bill
um who was actually sponsored by the
chairman of this Division and was a long
time in coming two years actually we
heard from uh technology on this so I
would look for at this point a motion to
retain House Bill 91 with the intention
that it be added to House Bill 2.
representative Doucet
I move we retain House Bill 91 with that
intent excellent is there a second
representative teleski as a second
okay any discussion House Bill 91 to be
retained with the intention of adding it
to House Bill 2 any discussion
real good okay our clerk who's doing a
phenomenal job by the way this session
this hasn't been easy with a lot of
twists and turns in this division but
you've been doing a phenomenal job
representative Stringham I think we're
ready for a a roll call on this if
you're ready
uh okay so this is the uh roll call to
retain house bill 91. uh uh I don't I
guess I would start with you still
representative Mooney yes representative
erf yes
uh representative Doucet yes
uh representative Wallner
representative nordengren yes
representative tolerski yes
and uh the clerk votes yes
representative Weiler votes yes okay uh
sorry about that thank you
excellent okay again with the
recommendation
unanimous to retain with an amendment to
House Bill 2 which we will exec next
week for those watching and online uh we
are executing house bills one and two on
Monday of next week and Wednesday of
next week house bills one and two is
that large okay we're going to move now
relative to including certain children
and pregnant women in Medicaid and the
children's health insurance program that
was sponsored by representative Shapiro
and we may recall his uh commitment to
this bill and his interest in it at this
point I would look for a motion to
retain House Bill 282 with the intention
of adding it to House Bill 2.
representative Doucet thank you amount
of Chad move we retain House Bill 282
with the intention of adding it to hb2
is there a second
representative walner for a second any
discussion
representative telersky
thank you madam chair I just wanted to
say I think that this bill is very
important when it comes to maternal and
Children's Health and as a Division I
hope we can continue to pursue similar
topics and I'm pleased to see It'll be
going into hb2
thank you for that any further
discussion all right if the clerk would
then call the roll
calling the role on House Bill 282
the motion is to retain the bill when
the intention of putting it in to hb2
representative Mooney yes
representative nordgren yes
representative tolerski yes
representative Stringham votes yes uh
um the vote being
six six to one does that sound right
seven to one where did him ah here we go
seven to one thank you
okay moving on now House Bill
565 and that is relative to expanding
Medicaid to include certain postpartum
Health Care Services bills sponsored by
representative M Murray I would look now
for a motion to retain with the
intention of adding to House Bill 2
which will be exact next Monday and
Wednesday next week representative
Doucet thank you madam chair I move
retention of House Bill 565 with the
intent to add it to hb2
and a second
representative walner for a second any
discussion House Bill 565
okay at this point if the clerk when
ready would call the roll
this is a vote on House Bill 565. uh the
motion is to retain with the intention
of inserting in-house Bill 2.
representative Mooney yes Representative
erf no
representative Doucet yes
representative walner
representative norngren yes
representative tolerski yes
representative Stringham yes
representative Weiler yes
final vote being seven to one the motion
passes
thank you representative Stringham
next moving on to House Bill 614 that's
making an appropriation to the
Department of Health and Human Services
to fund the Merrimack New Hampshire
kidney cancer incidence phase 3
feasibility study I would look now for a
motion to retain with the intention of
adding this exact language to House Bill
2. representative Doucet for emotion
thank you madam chair I move retention
on House Bill 614 with the intention of
adding it to hb2 Second
thank you and representative ER for a
second any discussion
okay at this point I would like to say
that I prepared some remarks on this
Merrimack is home to the biggest pfas
pollution in New Hampshire and thousands
have been affected either receiving
bottled water which they continue to do
to this day
installing filtration systems or
suffering with extreme health effects
this bill funds the recommendation for
phase three of a feasibility study to
fund High rates of kidney cancer
it was brought out in the work sessions
on this bill that only two times
in the last 10 years has a cancer study
been recommended to go from phase two to
phase three
this is extraordinary
the whole interest in pfas is the
effects it has on our human bodies and
on our environment and this phase three
would certainly benefit us as a state as
to the effects this has on the human
body
so to proceed with this phase from phase
two to phase three of the study
five hundred thousand dollars is needed
for fiscal years 24 and 25. two DHHS to
contract and proceed with the study so
it's critically important not only to my
community of Merrimack but to our state
as a whole that this bill be included
and passed as part of House Bill 2.
representative Weiler
I also appreciate the fact that we're
finally moving into looking at humans
rather than rodents because all these
past things have not really involved
humans at phase three and we've got some
of the lowest pfast
um things set down for the water which I
think is unreasonable unless we do some
human studies thank you
thank you any further comment
at this point I do see representative
Nancy Murphy in the audience she wasn't
able to make it to the work session
previous
would you like to say any comments at
thank you madam chair Nancy Murphy
Hillsboro 12 representing the town of
Merrimack I really appreciate the
support for this this bill it's
something that we in the community about
27 000 people
um know was an issue the the numbers in
our that cancer report actually are only
the numbers through 2018. so the
exceedings of I believe it was 19 cases
and with a 42 percent
over
um you know what should be expected in
terms of kidney cancer those numbers are
still much less than the reality of
what's happening so kidney cancer is
just one of the the health impacts that
we're concerned about and certainly
deserves you know this this feasibility
study and with ultimately probably an
epidemiological study for the reasons
you suggest that you know we're the the
need is not often found and it certainly
has been there given the exposure of our
community that Merrimack is sort of
Ground Zero for
um you know we've been designated these
uh site of the state's largest
industrial environmental disaster in the
state's history
um so it's it's this this money would be
really important to the division and to
to the the citizens Merrimack so I thank
thank you representative
okay any further discussion among the
members at this point we'll call the
role to retain House Bill 614 with the
intention of adding it to House Bill 2
representative Stringham representative
Mooney yes
representative erf yes
representative Doucet yes
representative walner
representative nordgren yes
representative tolerski yes uh clerk
votes yes represent representative
Weiler yes
uh final vote being eight and zero the
motion to passes
thank you so again as a reminder we'll
be executing house bills one and two on
Monday and Wednesday of next week
Tuesday of next week is a whole host of
bills that the finance the full finance
committee will be executing
so at this point is there anything
further from the members of division
three
okay Mr Ripple any closing words
nope
representative norgren
I just wanted to say you do a really
[Laughter]
and you'll notice that was an
unrecognized comment so represent dorgan
thank you very much for that I
appreciate that very much it means a lot
okay at representative Stringham okay
can we uh discuss at all what the
process looks like on uh on the hb1 hb2
um uh sessions on Monday and Wednesday
yes
representative Weiler so we'll start
with
since we're in division three and you
know you don't get to rotate around as
much as I do we'll start with division
one
and we'll see up there the chair and
vice chair and likely the two
LBA folks that will be assisting and
they'll start through the major points
as they go through
the different departments and the
different changes they made in briefing
us on what they did in the actions they
took as well as likely probably some of
the HBS that have been incorporated into
the budget and so we'll all have an
understanding of what happened within
that division
that will take some time and then we'll
go on to division two similar thing and
then division three and we'll all we'll
all get filled in on what
um and if if someone on division three's
leaves out something you think is
important you can
get get the attention and say hey don't
forget
what we did about so and so so that's
important that everybody they'll
allowable to be some other members of
the legislature I've invited them as you
heard and uh also maybe members of the
public and it will be telecast so it'll
go out and it will be kind of a
lengthier version of what we will do
when we present it in April to the Full
House and again it'll be division chairs
will get up Vice chairs and and kind of
give a description for
for some amount of time we don't haven't
decided yet of what took place I don't
think the Full House will listen for
hours
as we will probably have it here and uh
when we go through it but uh
that's kind of the purpose of it all and
then any other members that will come
before us I may still have another
meeting
tonight about uh
what we're wrapping up for those it's
been several members that come in that
want to know what happened someone be
likely having that meeting so anyway
that's
it's a sales job we have to let people
know that this is what we did
and we hope you support it and and
listen to see what the comments are or
questions and do our best to answer them
all so you know we're looking for
support on the budget from everybody on
the on the committee and from all the
members of the house so
we can send something on to the Senate
that we feel has a strong support thank
you
thank you representative walner
yes uh representative Weiler would
Monday as we're working on the reports
from each division would that be a time
that people could bring forth amendments
yes
and it'll be an exact session in effect
so we'll have the full committee here to
vote on it
so I guess that leads me to ask Mr
Ripple at some point between now and
Monday and I would assume that every
division would be in this situation a
list perhaps of all of the changes
amendments takeouts put-ins and the like
to House Bill 2 from this division so
the two documents that we generally
provide are a house bill 2 Amendment
packet containing all the house bill two
amendments that you passed along with
the summary sheet on the front and for
House Bill one we'll provide what we
call a detailed change document showing
all the line by line changes that were
made to the budget and so we'll finalize
those probably later tonight or tomorrow
and typically send them to the chairman
first so we can review them for a
real good any further discussion
okay with that I think we're ready to
close our work session today in division
three thank you all